au fur et à mesure que les cas de kobe
19 s'accumulent on découvre que le virus
peut avoir des conséquences à plus ou
moins long terme une fois l'infection
résorber des chercheurs s'intéressent
aux impacts du coroner virus sur le
coeur pour plusieurs
l'infection est déjà un lointain
souvenir
d'autres en subissent encore les effets
depuis son apparition la coved 19 a
contaminé près de 100 millions de
personnes dans le monde selon certaines
données
une personne sur dix atteinte de la
maladie ressentait encore des symptômes
trois mois après l'infection parmi ses
séquelles de la coved certaines
inquiètent particulièrement entre autres
celles qui touchent le coeur
[Musique]
au printemps le ch et celle des
sainte-dorothée à laval est devenue
tristement célèbre 211 résidents ont été
atteints de lakovic 19 cents sont
décédés parmi eux la mère de charles et
sa jian elle souffrait de la maladie
d'alzheimer elle avait 91 ans flosse
elle était censée être en sécurité mais
un jour on m'a appelé pour me dire qu'il
avait la queue vide en avril monsieur et
sadien a passé trois jours au chevet de
sa mère mourante
malgré toutes les précautions il a lui
aussi attrapé la maladie était très
malade
la meilleure façon de décrire c'est la
pire pneumonie imaginables je ne pouvais
pas sortir du lit j'étais épuisé mes
proches m'ont envoyé des messages et je
n'avais même pas la force de répondre
par texto quelques mois plus tard il se
sentait mieux mais avait encore parfois
des douleurs à la poitrine en novembre
son médecin l'a envoyé ici au centre
universitaire de santé mcgill pour
passer un examen relativement peu commun
en cardiologie une résonance magnétique
ou irm la spécialité du cardiologue
mathias friedrich
on voit ici le coeur se contracter et
normalement cette contraction est
uniforme
la beauté de l'irm c'est qu'on peut non
seulement voir comment le coeur
fonctionne mais aussi ce qui se passe
dans les tissus
quand il est normal
le muscle cardiaque apparaît en vert
anormal en rouge
voici une image d'une patiente qui a eu
une forme sévère de l'aco vide on voit
que presque tout le muscle et rouge
ça veut dire que c'est tout en fait
[Musique]
cette enflure du coeur décrite par le
cardiologue c'est une inflammation aussi
appelé myocardite de scouts bien nos
stocks cette enflure persistantes
empêchent le muscle du coeur de se
remplir correctement ils pompent le sent
moins efficacement et c'est pour ça que
les patients peuvent se sentir fatigué
et soufflé ou avoir des palpitations
tout ça peut être lié à une malle
fonction du muscle cardiaque ce genre d'
inflammation cardiaque n'est pas
exclusif à la coved 19 d'autres virus
comme celui de la grippe peuvent avoir
des effets similaires mais ils sont
généralement de courte durée domicile
chez des patients qui ont développé des
symptômes de l'aco vide on voit que 20 à
30 % d'entre eux semblent avoir cette
enflure qui peut perdurer pendant des
semaines ou des mois
combien auront des séquelles à long
terme ce n'est pas encore clair
pourquoi le virus sras skov deux atteint
10 le coeur de cette façon
l'explication réside ray dans sa méthode
d'entrer dans nos cellules
[Musique]
contrairement à d'autres virus celui ci
entre dans nos cellules via le récepteur
à ce2 ce récepteur est normalement
impliquée dans le contrôle de la
pression sanguine et la perméabilité des
vaisseaux sanguins détermine si les
vaisseaux fui ou non si ces récepteurs à
ce2 sont inactivées par le virus
la régulation des échanges nous est
affecté et l'eau peut s'échapper loup
qui s'accumulent fait gonfler le muscle
cardiaque
la pression dans le coeur augmente il
perd de son élasticité et de sa capacité
à pomper correctement le sang dans
l'organisme ans
[Musique]
le phénomène est observé chez des
patients qui avaient déjà des problèmes
cardiaques avant la qu'ovide mais aussi
chez des gens auparavant en parfaite
santé dont certaines ont ressenti que
peu voire pas de symptômes pendant leur
infection qu'elle pourrait être alors
l'impact de cette inflammation cardiaque
qui risque d'en être affecté pour en
avoir le coeur net
l'équipe du docteur friedrich entame une
étude qui prévoit suivre 400 patients
entre les symptômes qui perdure parfois
après l'infection au niveau du coeur
mais aussi par exemple la fatigue ou les
difficultés de concentration pourrait
être associé au coeur mais aussi au
cerveau nous voulons vérifier si cet
oedème du muscle cardiaque est associée
à tout ça dans la plupart des cas
l'inflammation devrait se résorber
d'elle-même mais le cardiologue est
quand même inquiet car un coeur en flic
est encore fragile qu'il faut savoir
c'est que si vous faites de l'exercice
de manière intensive pendant vous avez
cette inflammation
ça pourrait causer des dommages
permanents au coeur autrement dit quand
nos grands mères nous disait si tu as de
la fièvre reste au lit elle avait raison
pour charles et sa jian l'inflammation
est bien là mais ne semble pas trop
inquiétante que c'est bon signe
j'ai assez souffert comme ça
[Musique]